[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today were joined by ISA ray she's
the emmy-nominated creator and star of
HBO's hit series insecure now in its
third season catch it on sundays 10:30
p.m. eastern glowing up an easy Easter
ray welcome to the show Matt thank you
for having me you said in a recent AMA
that you can never have enough hot sauce
so I take it you're comfortable around
spicy wings I love spicy food but I also
had to come for a you know water and
next to me so I'm gonna just you know
eat you ready to get it going I'm ready
to get it going
[Music]
[Music]
all right so this first one is the
howler monkey and you'll start at the
handle started to handle all right
I'm so hungry so thank you okay I start
off with a little slice and cello so we
couldn't get you in here without talking
about insecure season 3 the streets are
buzzing I see billboards all over the
place but we have what we get into it I
think we need to address the elephant
the room and that's lawrence hive the
cut described lawrence hive is the male
answer to the bee hive for the
uninitiated what is lawrence hive and
what effect has it had on your life hmm
lawrence i've has had no effect on my
life I mean it's minute it's been great
because so many guys are invested in the
show and the fact that they've rallied
around J Ellis as he's playing this
earnest character is incredible but
they're out of hand
they're out of pocket they're really
really intense which is what you dream
of when you create a show of all the l8
restaurants that you guys are featured
on the show which is your favorite to
visit in real life Wow
there's more this season like we got our
place call pans the season which I like
eat breakfast at all the time whenever I
can the line I love Roy Choi's
restaurants and we got the pot they're
calm high Islamic commissary we filmed
at the table o marcado of course first
episode pilot Ethiopian food that
restaurant is what's like my first
introduction one of my first
introductions in a late to Ethiopian
food this one's really good I first like
barbecue okay
but you can still taste no I think it's
just scorched earth like it's good okay
that's not gonna boss at all you have a
competitive edge so while at Stanford
you created a webseries dorm Diaries
which you said was birthed from
procrastination and being on YouTube
constantly do you remember the web shows
or Internet videos that you're watching
back then people lip-synching people at
the zoo oh there are a lotta there was a
applies video that I used to love he did
like this reality show called busty baby
and it is the most iconic video to this
day that I've ever seen I don't even
know if it's done on the internet but a
lot of just colleagues people creating
stuff and then you're big about writing
what you know when it's clear from
watching awkward black girl and from
watching insecure that you've had some
boring as helll 9 to 5 s in your life
when I think back about the strange jobs
you had before show business are there
any that stand out um yeah working in a
slave ship at a museum yeah that was
hard you know not as hard as slavery but
it was depressing to be there every
single day and that was yeah I'm glad
I'm out I'm glad I made it up so this
next one is the Pirates Lantern who
names these the pirate Lantern like cuz
fire mm-hmm okay I get it okay I don't
like it it's bitter it has some mustard
action to it I'm sorry pirates laner
you'll need to apologize okay so if
anyone ever gave hot ones a 1 million
dollar budget I have no idea of what we
do with the money how we'd spend it so
I'm curious when HBO gave you your first
big bag to make insecure season 1 what
was the most awesome thing about having
money and then what was like the biggest
waste I used to do this for $5 in my
dorm room thing oh man oh definitely
going in the Staples Center and shooting
a fake hockey game expensive super
expensive and wills dumped up by HBO's
we were gonna try to fake it cuz really
the kind of flirts are good the stateful
son of they're real games happening and
we were gonna like pass it up on the
budget and then shout out to Amy grab it
one of the executives is like look if
Silicon Valley can shoot in in the
Staples Center so can insecure so let's
make a band don't fake this let's do it
for real I was like we gotta like that
and the most waste of money thing that
still infuriates me is when we have to
shoot like car scenes she did a lot of
this season it takes like hours to set
up because you have to have like a
process trailer and we used to just like
I used to be like home and get in the
car I'm gonna drive you get you driving
the next car you just hold the camera
like this and we got the shot you know
or put a camera on the dashboard and
it's so expensive and time-consuming
that they won't just let you put a
camera on the car let's say there's
someone watching this in Omaha Nebraska
they're 1,500 miles away from Hollywood
and they have in their hands what they
think is the best screenplay since the
Godfather how would you suggest they get
someone important to read it
someone just yesterday stopped me I was
walking a time squared with the walking
through Times Square because I wanted to
see our billboard I've never seen a
billboard that large and I figure out
there it's awesome and this guy stopped
me he was like whoa I may never have a
chance to see you again every time mommy
I'm walking here and he was like I wrote
this screenplay and I just want to know
like what do I need to do and I was like
make a trailer make that [ __ ] show
people why they want to see it and then
people will come to you and I think
that's my biggest thing if your thing is
the next Godfather if you have a teaser
trailer for or you shoot a scene that's
phenomenal that piques people's interest
we're just an age where everybody's just
like ready to support was dope
this one is interesting - so you're a
child of the internet a master at the
craft of relationship writing and a
self-proclaimed professional stalker
what I want to do is take an opportunity
to talk to you about the bizarre world
of dating in the age of technology do
you think that apps like tinder and the
league are a net positive or a net
negative for the dating scene you're
trying to hook up we can be instead like
what perfect if you're trying to get to
know someone then like so many people
have these days because we have so many
options it's so easy to get turned off
by one thing like you could write the
wrong thing on your profile and be
ridiculed for it it's just another way
to meet people and make the world a
flatter place we have a friend that
responds to every tinder match by saying
we did it with two trophy emojis is that
genius or the worthless psychopath every
match every match he hits them with we
did it in two trophy emojis and it's
that's insincere I don't like it
I don't thinking about and then the
writing and insecure is really on the
zeitgeist but there are a few places
where millennial slang travels faster
than in the world of dating so what I
want to do is hit you with some new
school dating terms and if you know them
maybe you can define them for the
audience out there and if you don't know
them maybe you can guess what they mean
okay they're all real they're all real
bread crumbing what bread bread crumbing
mm-hmm is that like when you are these
[Music]
is that when you like all right eat it
is like extra [ __ ] crumbs so what it is
leading someone on with the trail of
flirtatious messages but then shutting
them out was close
you're very close very close bunchy
benching oh when you're like taking a
break from your hose right you have a
rotation you have a rostered and you
gotta put one to the side you gotta put
a couple on the bench yes Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing he's cuffing season cuffing
season is that time usually
during winter months maybe starting in
fall late fall where you gotta find a
boo to stay warm there it is and then
the slow fade
oh is that when you're basically good
thing you kind of like give a message
here and there you slowly back away
mm-hmm and then one more kitten fishing
that sounds I don't wanna be set up but
I think about kitten nothing about [ __ ]
mm-hmm it is lesser form of catfishing
like using old pictures or having a
witty friend text for you I love that
you like Cyrano de Bergerac messages and
through the text that is a very good
name okay let's come into first of all
these wings are bound where they
actually from a thank you I was about to
take credit for them like I made them
but we get them from place called my
belly's playlist my belly's playlist is
on point
mm-hmm alrighty so we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
Graham where you do a deep dive and I
guess Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so I'll
bust out the laptop I'll show you the
picture and then you tell me the bigger
story is that sound good my Instagram of
your Instagram but we actually pulled
some Gettys laptop IDs all right Lisa
first things first
haha all-star game with Diddy that was a
blast I wasn't I didn't go with him I
wish I did but it was my first time
meeting him and I was just sitting
courtside I got tickets and he was
diagonal and he came over and asked for
a picture with me and Minnie invited me
to lunch he was like let's go to lunch
and I was like okay this is Hollywood it
was like no I want to have you over my
house for night and then he really text
me and followed through and I was in the
writers room and I was like guys I gotta
go to did his house for lunch didn't
tell the mat and I thought it was gonna
be a quick thing but he tried to have
like a full-course meal and you're
thinking it was incredible but I was
like get back to work he was like ok
that's ok we'll rush it bring all the
courses out at once and I felt bad I
haven't been back all right
do you have a Tiffany story do I have a
Tiffany story I have a lot of Tiffany's
stories but I'm not gonna say him cuz
that's what we do right two stories stay
between us
I do who never mind I'm not gonna tell
that story once you can't leave us there
I will say one of my first times getting
to hang out with Tiffany she met is one
of my favorite stories she met one of
our cast members who shall remain
nameless I had a little party in my
hotel room at essence Fest her moon
girls trip had just come out we'd just
all come from seeing the premiere there
and she was like what a party yet and I
was like girls in my hotel come through
and then we can go other places and she
meets one of our cast members comes into
the door does a beeline and it's like
hey I'm Tiffany has a champagne glass in
her hand and it's like ham tipping in
demonstrates her skills what he's like
okay and so then throughout the night
she was drinking more and she sat next
to him and got in his face and was just
like you look like a [ __ ] that likes
to get slapped I'm a slap it he was like
well actually I don't I don't like to
get slapped and she was like yes you do
I'm gonna slap you right now you'll come
and just continued to berate him but
then when he told this story later he
was like oh yeah Tiffany was tryna holla
and omitted that part right which tells
me that I think he actually likes to get
slapped I'll let you guess - the cast
member was
so this is where you said it starts to
get gets layered I mean I can see which
is more on my nose just did a little pop
okay black garlic
okay Carolina Reaper is that that hot
super hot pepper
yeah I've eaten two of those actually
you've eaten the actual peppers yeah
like the full pod popped it two times
why did you do this for the views
respect so insecure has joined the likes
of shows like entourage in the OSI with
this incredible track record for
breaking music I'm curious what goes
into sound tracking a season of insecure
do you guys fight over tracks who's the
taste maker
what's the BTS on that um lots of love
you know it started with salons being
our music consultant that was great but
I've always known like firm jump I was
like our show could be trashed but the
music is gonna be fired cuz music
informs so much of like how much I see
things and even huh right we had so many
songs that we loved in common like even
for choosing broken [ __ ] we had to
initially it was set to Missy's
sock-it-to-me
I love that song and I insisted that
track was fire but we couldn't get the
rights to it in time and so Solange sent
a whole bunch of alternative options and
bossy was on there and it was like the
perfect fit
and then since then we'll find
independent artists female artists must
what no you look great
you look great glowing up ain't easy as
they say no it's not so this next one is
the bun stirs black label out of
Australia Australia doesn't play I
already know I'm worried
[Music]
it's like lemony okay with lemony and
spicy mm-hmm just want to focus on the
ISA raid do-it-yourself blueprint
because we've touched on a little bit
today you went from making web shows in
your dorm room to then making this hit
emmy-nominated show for HBO what was
your first mom I made it moment mom mom
I made it more of dad I made it cuz dad
was the one that was hard to impress was
being on NPR because I was like oh you I
know you [ __ ] with NPR dad
so stop telling me to go to grad school
cuz you heard me on this you know but
even when I felt like after NPR I got an
opportunity to work with Sean Dave and
sent it to the group chat like the
family group chat and he was still like
okay great when you want to grad school
about what's the most ridiculous gossip
headline you've ever read about yourself
then I turned right down at a party that
it was dope I was like Greg give me some
clout but is ridiculous cuz I'm a huge
fan
all right ISA you ready to move on I
don't know I really don't I'm going back
and eating these because of my mom and
my family weekend
[Music]
okay it tastes hot no this is one of
those things that's gonna kick him it is
I answer my place with minimal trip okay
still going in okay alright ISA heard
that you're always a TV obsessive more
so than film and with as much ground as
insecure has broken it embraces humor
and awkwardness which is part of a
larger comedy genre so what I want to do
is show you some icons of that genre and
then just get your snap reaction to them
alright so I'll just show you but you're
still going in because it's literally
delicious alrighty so first things first
I really didn't hear your question cuz
my mouth was learning Curb Your
Enthusiasm favoritest ever love learing
Arrested Development I've watched the
seasons four times now and that laugh
and find something need every single
time I wish I could tell the story that
brilliantly the office the greatest
sitcom ever and one of the best love
stories on television and one more for
you Parks and Recreation ome pota career
goals I also love Donna and Parks and
Rec she gave us treat yourself which is
my mantra treat yourself yes should be
treat ourselves to another wing I was a
good transition
[Music]
alright Hellfire this I can see cuz
aspects of hot
looks like someone's spit on this would
[Music]
this interviews over tough one but still
this is too much that picture if they
have like a psychotic clown on the front
this is smiling and it's fiery fool I
feel foolish for heating it so know that
you really began honing your craft while
at Stanford so I'm curious what's one
stanford stereotype that's totally off
and then one that holds true like is
there anything to that stanford duck
syndrome thing oh that is there's yes
there's a lot to that I love that
actually about the description of
Stanford students just in terms of for
people who aren't familiar people like
act like oh yeah I'm taking 22 unisom
you know it's no big deal and they look
like they're floating but beneath
they're just paddling to stay afloat and
that's definitely a true thing people
would always try to front like this [ __ ]
is hard just say it's hard you're
struggling because we are live but it's
a great community
I always thought people were gonna be
stuck up I didn't want to go there I
didn't apply but going there for like
the admin weekend was like oh [ __ ] with
the school and then while you were there
you made a couple dorm room music videos
do you have a favorite bar from work in
the V or non epoch a favorite bar 95 yes
because I felt like we inspired cardd I
don't care ok it was 90 pops with a
friend 90 pops with a man you can't even
do you the 90 pop on a handstand that
was all free stuff I was so proud of
myself
all right Easter ray this is the last
tab we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing you don't have to
if you don't want to if you're doing it
I'm doing it there we go it's going down
so this is running this [ __ ] here we go
my throat burns what a ride it's been
[Music]
this is yours that you made
[Music]
looks like you'd like to
just top it off
it really sees the place
[Music]
well that's how we close it out ISA and
from the howler monkey to the last dab
the glow-up is just a little bit too
real but there's just one more hurdle
standing between you in the finish line
your character and insecure is famous
for revealing her truest Rost emotions
when she's doing these mere freestyles
so now that you can see your own
reflection and the sauces that you've
conquered today can you hit the people
with a few bars about your fight your
battle with the wings of death um you
know I don't do this alright I'm a
terrible freestyle
sitting here with my [ __ ] wings
I'm doing this [ __ ] like hot things I'm
so fly get a chicken wing in my mouth
imma die but I got the heat just like
these wings
if you mad at me I'm gonna bring you
with the things that means my guns I am
the one hot son get the gun that was
amazing it was brilliant I'm inspired
and look at you all the way through the
wings of death ten wings up ten wings
down and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you Issa
Rae wow wow this camera at this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life um I'm suffering right
now but I'm just so excited cuz season
three of insecure premieres Sunday 10:30
every Sunday watch it with your friends
put some on someone new on to it thank
you for feeding me I was very hungry I
think that's the only reason I survived
I want to see if this works
please you would no water no milk I did
wow you know that's actually a kind of a
legendary thing is it and people when
they go no my daughter no milk they make
such a big deal of it look I'm going no
water no milk but like you just casually
did it I don't know that I was allowed
to thank you that's great questions
million to 1 million three that's pretty
good form Phil then you get that cool
shirt
you didn't hear how ones merch it's
available now I thought you only wore
Where's Waldo shirts I used to wear
Where's Waldo shirts one
[Music]